hello everyone I hope you're all having
a wonderful Saturday and as we already
mentioned we are going to show at least
one more game from round six of the 2019
Tata Steel chess tournament it's again
between post grandmaster yung shue stuff
Duda and Dutch of Grand Master onigiri
as you all know one is Irie a won first
place last year in the Tata Steel but he
was tied with Magnus Carlsen they had to
go into tiebreaks
and then Magnus Carlsen one in tiebreaks
as in tiebreaks there are faster time
controls and it's always very difficult
to play against Magnus Carlsen in faster
time controls as everyone always is
reminded of that Karekin got reminded of
that after he you know got through the
classical time formats in his 2016 World
Chess Championship match against Carlsen
and then across and defeated him in the
rapid Caruana also saw this after
drawing 12 games against Coulson and
then losing to him in faster time
controls and Giri saw it in last year's
Tata Steel tournament where again he
finished first time with Carlson and he
had to play against him in faster time
controls so here now I'm Akira has the
black pieces and after losing that first
game to yan upon Yoshi
uniform yoshua always messed it up but I
will just call him neppo until I master
that yeah after he blundered a piece in
round one
he had a perfect tournament afterwards
and here again he plays a very
interesting game with the black pieces
or should I say young she still do the
plays are very interesting him with the
white pieces but I'll let you decide on
who played an interesting game here so
Duda opens with E 4 we have e5 Knight f3
knight c6 and here we have g3 definitely
not a mu you see every day in top-tier
tournaments it's the constant you know
Polsky opening introduced by alexandra
constantinople ski in 1956 game against
vyacheslav I was in and I mean of course
it can be used as as a surprise now III
don't think I've seen this move ever in
in top-tier tournaments but okay here it
goes
Knight to f6 with d3 g 6 and
Bishop to g2 preparing the castle Gary
also prepares the castle and here there
are a few moves known in the database
Knight c3 is a known move Bishop g5 is a
known move castling is a known move but
c4 is a new move and already on move six
we have a completely new game so
obviously do that prepared something
devious for for Geary this game we have
d6 simply strengthening the center here
and as you can see c4 and c5 create a
very strong outpost on d5 Abunda but on
the other hand creates a hole on d4 so
it's a trade off as usual when you when
you leave your for example backwards
deep on a d3 point week like this h3 we
have castles by gearing in Knights the
c3 and not Knight to d7 already this is
not your everyday opening and well you
have to you have to immediately start
thinking and which is not very often the
case in talk to your tournaments usually
will have maybe even play 20 moves
before you have to go out of you know
safety waters of opening theory
knowledge here gira wants to bust open
the position with f5 with Bishop to g5
attacking gear is queen and now first f6
now we have the shot back to e3 and now
f5 and now although you could play
Bishop to g5 once again hoping to repeat
a position I mean you're playing the
white pieces of course you don't want to
repeat positions and it's definitely
Duda who is more prepared this game as
he prepared this Constantino Polsky
opening for Geary for example if Bishop
f6 then Bishop h6 but black can even
ignore even play F captures on e4 and
now you cannot capture drug because of
capturing here for example captures
captures and now you will lose the one
of the bishops hereafter but your
characters Queen captures you will when
to Oh black will win two pieces for the
rook which is definitely in White's
favor
so after ef5 we have eight characters on
f5 and now G captures on f5 giri allows
is a pawn structure on the King side to
be ruined by
in as a reward he will have a very nice
control of the center here and under the
kingside and he will be able to create
an attack on the kingside Queen d2
hoping to exchange your bishops via
Bishop to h6 and now comes Knight to c5
Gary's preparing to bring this Knight
over to e6 and then he will have
excellent control of deef of d4 but also
he will prepare f4 we have castles by do
to enter not nice to e6 Knight to d5 and
now Geary way it's no longer
he plays f4 and it's it's a very nice
idea G captures on f4 and now not
recapturing but rather a knight C to d4
and here you do have to you do have to
capture with the bishop because if you
capture with the night then it's a bit
of a problem for example if Knight
captures he captures then your Bishop on
e3 is trapped and while you can free it
for example with f5 it's it's a very
complicated idea but it doesn't work in
the end because here after pawn captures
this is not the best way to continue for
black after why to recapture so white
will actually have a very strong center
and a very strong initiative now the
pawn on f5 is protected and black will
still have to struggle here so instead
of capturing on e3 black will just
capture on f5 and now black is just
better your Bishop is still under attack
for as I'm example in Bishop h6 now c6
attacking the knight the knight cannot
retreat the e3 or f4 so Knight have to
test has to go to b4 and now after Queen
h4 black will simply have a deadly
attack
for example Bishop captures black can
ignore him night at for the attack is
coming after f3 you can go Queen g3
threaten and Knight captures on h3 after
King h1 you can go
rook h5 and now you're just threatening
everything Bishop captures on h3 is a
big threat at queen of 2 you can simply
grab the bishop be back after Luke g1
now you can just capture here a bunch of
characters rook captures with check you
have to block with the Queen you lose
the Queen and then black will not lose
his Queen as 96 simply stops everything
so a very dangerous position here after
a night C to D for by giri
so do that decides the capture with the
bushel we have Bishop captures each
capture son d4 and now Queen to a5 giver
says ok that's weird move go back with
the Queen he plays b6 and indeed dude
ugly does go back with the Queen
we have c6 pressuring the night and now
it's a bit of a problem here if you go
night b4 which is definitely an option
then comes Knight captures and f4 and
blacks attack will will be too strong
for example Knight captures on c6 Queen
f6 now you can go Queen g6 you can
capture on h3 everything is an idea here
black will just have an unstoppable
attack one of the possibilities after c6
is again this f5 move which leads to a
very interesting position if of course
if black captures here then you will
capture on e6 but if rook captures then
you can go Queenie for attack the rook
and now I have to look to f7 you can go
night b4
save your night but still black will go
back from d7 and after Knight captures
on c6 Queen f8 and blacks attack will
still be happening much faster than
whites and it's just a better position
so do that decides to go for a different
idea not moving the knight not pushing
f5 but rather a knight g5 and indeed if
you if you decide to capture the pawn
here then you get the knight captures
here and Bishop captures Queen captures
and e6 would check King moves and now
Bishop captures on d5 equalizes in
material but White's position will be
will be better here so giri decides to
to defend instead after Knight g5 we
have rook e8 defending and now what do
you play here if you capture on e6 then
rook captures on e6 you have to move the
Queen rook g6 again Black's attack is
happening much faster on the other hand
after rook to e8 if you try something
like Knight be four again retreating
with the night again Knight captures on
f4 will be a much much faster attack for
Black Knight captures Queen d7 and now
your queen is under attack the knight is
under attack this Bishop Knight captures
Bishop followed by Queen captures on h3
is an idea but still if Queen c1 simply
not capture skin characters and Queen
captures here will be winning
for black after king g1 but should be
seven you have this very nice diagonal
here just a crushing position for black
and even black is up a piece so after
rook e8 we have Queen to d1 getting the
Queen out of this nasty rooks efile and
now still not capturing here if you
capture here then now White's idea is
still very very interesting after Bishop
captures you pin the night and there's a
double attack on the night but also
Queen G for Queen g5 isn't a queen h5 is
an idea let's say if you try something
like Queen to f6 then you get rook to e1
a triple attack against the knight and
e6 and now let's say if something like
h6 you can go Queen to h5 attack the
look that is undefended here and then
after but should be 70 after you connect
rooks you get rook captures on e6 rook
captures Knight captures and now after
Bishop captures here you will get Queen
captures attacking the rook but also
threatening or all sorts of nasty
discoveries after row b8 you will get
King to h2 preferring rook to g1 and
after black also on pins roof to G 1 is
coming black a white moves for attack or
simply coming to natural rook g8 and
then for example you can go Queen
captures on d6 or or whatever and
whatever move black makes it's it's very
hard for black to make a move let's say
you try here ad then white can even just
capture recapture some g7 rook captures
and now Knight of fate to check will
pick up the Queen here either by moving
the King and then the Queen is picked up
or you will capture and then the Queen
captures will be winning so you know
definitely a lot of poison to this Queen
to d1 move but Giri doesn't go for the
d5 Knight first he just captures on g5
we have F captures and now C captures on
d5 and now Giri is definitely up a piece
we have Bishop captures on d5 with check
and now not a retreating with a king but
Bishop to e6 you have to protect the
rook with the Queen so the bishop has to
move with Bishop captures Queen captures
on a8 and now Queen to h5 and now as you
can see GUI has two bishops for a rope
and sometimes the rook who will prevail
against two bishops but as you can see
here the the two bishops are very active
and
the rooks are not really developed just
yet and it's very hard to imagine how
they will you know become developed
Bishop to a5 attacking the pawn on d3 I
will have located the one defending and
now comes look to e5 just you know
bringing more activity to this rook and
also preparing to attack this pawn on g5
we have looked the d2 and the now comes
Queen to d8 we have h4 with further
protection to the g5 pawn and now Bishop
to h3 attacking the rook on f1 and here
white is already in in a pretty bad bad
spot if you move to work let's say rook
F d1 then Queen 208 threatens checkmate
you have to further weaken your position
let's say f4 to protect g2 but then
rocky 3 rook g3 is coming and white is
just falling apart so here after Bishop
to h3 we have Queen to f3 I'll do that
decides to give up the exchange here
with rush of captures King captures on
f1 and now h6 Gary is now up a full
piece and as long as he can avoid any
perpetual checks he he will definitely
win this game we have G captures on h6
Bishop captures on h6 and now rook to
eat you
well you can capture here a giri decides
to first go Queen e7 we have Queen to g4
check King to have 7 and now Queen back
to f3 check giver repeats King g7 we
have Queen to g4 check team to f7 and
Queen to f3 check Duda is down a piece
so he of course would definitely enjoy
repeating this perpetual but as Giri is
up a piece he wants to win this game so
Queen to a6 offering a queen trade Queen
- b7 check with King to g6 and not rook
captures on e5 d captures on e5 and now
came to e2 and now ok the king is
somewhat open on g6 perhaps some ideas
of Perpetual checks are possible Queen
to f4 we have King back to f1 and now
King to h5 the king will be much safer
there we have before and now comes queen
c1 check King to g2 and now King
captures on h4 Queen captures on a 7 if
you can eliminate this point as well
then perhaps your
huge punch in on the queenside can be of
some you know significance we have Queen
back to g5 check King to f1 and now King
to h3 and here it's already becoming
very dangerous if this King for example
takes away all of the squares here then
the checks from the Queen will be very
deadly we have Queen to h7 but now comes
Queen to h5 and here after this Queen to
h5 duel ahead enough and it was in this
position that young shift of Duda
resigned the game now there's not all
that much you can do queen d1 is the
threat of checkmate as the king
discovering the g2 square and it's very
hard to avoid this for example if you
try something like King you want then
the shop today to check checks the king
and who wins the Queen and h7 and if you
don't do that if you try something like
let's say Queenie for so you can meet
Queen d1 check with blocking Queen e1
and then you can just start grabbing
material Queen captures on d3 and now if
you go to g1 then it will be for
checkmate Queen g6 check you can go back
King to a form but now d3 you take away
this Square from from the King so this
will be again a threat of checkmate so
you can try Queenie for but no not Queen
B for that loses the Queen but let's say
if Queen captures only 5 then again
Queen G to check King has to move and
now Queen h1 will again be checkmate as
the pawn and Bishop are controlling
these two squares and on the other hand
after this let's say Queen D 1 check you
block and after this capture you block
again with the Queen you don't go King G
1 then you can just start grabbing more
material Queen B 1 share Queen blocks
Queen captures on a - let's say you go
here captures captures black will just
to go back and this point will soon be
lost black is now will be upper phone
and the bishop and white black has too
many threats you can just pretty much
exchange Queens whenever you want and it
will be over very quickly so yeah after
this Queen h5 move do the resign the
game and another very nice win with
foreigners giri with the black pieces
and I believe so far he has 100
sent winrate with the black pieces of
this tournament and here I did prepare
the standings after round six as as
promised so here they are we have a four
player tie for first place
unless you're reading leerin Magnus
crossing and nipple then we have
Vishwanathan Anand and we did Gujarati
also tied with three and a half points
then with three point three points team
order job of Mahmud ER after losing his
game to Carlsen with two and a half
Samuel Shanklin also with two and a half
out of six richard report and a young
feast of Duda also with two and a half
then we have federal safe and kramnik
with two points not having the greatest
tournament so far and Jordan one forest
with two out of six he was able to win
one more game so you know getting
getting up there yeah and also here is
something very well we could say
enjoyable user on Twitter named young
Tiger 51 said I have a strong feeling
that onigiri is going to win the status
steel chess as clear first where Magnus
Carlsen is also a participant let's see
fingers crossed I replied to him that I
think he would either like to be clear
first or not first at all definitely not
up for tiebreaks like last year as we
already mentioned that last year he lost
the cross and in Thai breaks and then I
mentioned who knows he might have been
brushing up on his speed and then
onigiri replied with this with this gif
of Trump saying wrong which you know
obviously he's referring to that to the
first part of my sentence that however I
said I think he would either like to be
clear first or not first at all so
basically gear is saying that he is
ready for anything that if he will have
to go into tiebreaks against Carson that
he's ready for that and if he is indeed
ready for that then he well will be the
first one to ever be ready for that as
so far no one was able no one has been
able to do this and if he's definitely
able to do this then he is perhaps
world championship challenger material
but yeah definitely an interesting turn
of events and you know
I'll be very happy to see how this whole
thing turns out yeah I would like to
thank our Ando Liana Peter Simmons Adam
Greece Adam Drai's here captains and the
David sacks for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it with his contribution
David sacks joins Rae Fowler and Sean
Wilcox and as Top Contributor of
agamotto chest challenge chest channel
so congratulations for that
and yeah as usual you can check - on my
previous videos here I think all for
watching and I will see you soon have an
excellent rest of the Saturday hopefully
I will be able to drop a couple Blanca
video today as well thank you all and
I'll see you soon